okay thank you all for coming today um
to our conference
entitled rocco oyerbach the bridge
between wartime and post-war testimony
my name is stephen naren and i'm the
director of the fortune off video
archive for holocaust testimonies this
is the 12th event in the fortune off
archives 2019 event series marking 40
years of recording video testimony and
indeed about 40 years ago on may 2nd
1979 laurel vlog and dory loud recorded
the first four testimonies that would
establish the holocaust survivors film
project the immediate predecessor to the
yale's fortune off video archive for
holocaust testimonies and we are still
recording testimony today
uh in fact a few weeks ago joanne
rudolph and sue millen recorded a
testimony with a french child survivor
at yale's broadcast studio
from its beginning the holocaust
survivors film project was built funded
and staffed by many survivors as best
embodied by william rosenberg a survivor
from chance jehovah
who served as the president of the
project prior to its arrival at yale
the first 183 recordings from the
holocaust survivors film project came to
yale in 1981 with the help of jeffrey
hartman professor jeffrey hartman who
fled on a kinder transport from
frankfurt his wife renee was one of the
first four survivors recorded in 1979
and under jeffrey's leadership and
joanne rudolph's stewardship this
collection grew to encompass more than 4
400 testimonies of survivors witnesses
and bystanders we now have 12 000 hours
of recorded material in over a dozen
languages recorded in a dozen
different countries
i'd like to thank a number of
individuals for making this conference
possible first to the speakers who have
come far and wide from as far as israel
germany and poland showing him showing
him dunk thank you for your willingness
to share your scholarship your
intellectual labor your dedication to
what oyerbach accomplished and stands
for
my thanks to the fortune of blaustein
ross libby and cole families and the
many other donors to the archive for
their unflagging support
i'd like to thank our honorary advisory
board and our faculty advisors council
in particular i'd like to thank sam
moyne
who gave me the creative spark for
organizing this event series
it's a year-long event series and who
helped me together with sam cassow
build an exciting um series with this
conference this or about conference at
its heart
although there are several more
events in the series and i encourage you
all to attend again i want to emphasize
this really was the beginning of the
entire event series and marks a sort of
climax of this year-long effort so thank
you sam's plural
i'd like to express my gratitude for the
support displayed by susan gibbons
university librarian
and my supervisor christine weidemann
the director of manuscripts and archives
as well as maurice samuels and renee
reed at yale's today studies program
i'd also like to thank yale's program
for the study of anti-semitism david
simon at yale's genocide studies program
and doug rogers at yale's russian east
european and eurasian studies program
finally i'd like to thank the fortunate
archive staff and post-docs in
particular deborah bush today would not
have been possible without deborah's
incredible organizational skill
her patience and uh in getting every
detail right regarding travel logistics
and catering etc
deborah has worked at yale for more than
40 years
and more than two decades at the fortune
off video archive she's our
institutional memory an administrative
oracle of delphi
and the heart of the archive sustaining
all aspects of the work we do
so please join me in thanking her
i'm certain that i forgot i forgot many
other individuals who my thanks and i
hope they will forgive me for my
omissions
before i introduce today's keynote
speaker and i'm going to cut my
my presentation short because we're
already running behind
i just wanted to say a few things about
why the fortune off archive is
organizing a conference like this today
i believe that the connection between
oil box work and the archive is
self-evident but that connection may not
be as clear to the rest of you
after all erbach died in 1976 three
years before the fortune of archives
predecessor organization began taping in
new haven
but as her as head of yad vashem's oral
testimony section her work set a path
that we would follow and expand upon
urite neumann at yad vashem was kind
enough to give me a copy of oyerbach's
oral testimony guidelines which is an
18-page hebrew document which i had
translated it was drafted in 1962.
she compiled it as a manual for the
poorly paid staff and you can see how
poorly paid the staff was in the
guidelines that she's telling them not
to you know not to give up hope despite
how how poorly they're paid
and the teams have a team of volunteers
recording testimonies for yad vashem
when i read it it was no surprise to me
that her motivations for recording
testimony and her methodology so clearly
foreshadowed the work the fortunate
archive would start in new haven and i
quote
the testimonies we collect from
holocaust survivors are one of the most
important jewish sources to preserve and
research a time of devastation these
testimonies will help countless future
researchers teachers psychologists
sociologists students and ordinary
people learn about the holocaust from
those who survived it
she continues making explicit
the connection between past efforts to
do this and her present work
by naming emmanuel ringlebloom as the
first man the first
man to perform an organized
documentation work as a way to record
the events of world war ii
already composing the first
questionnaires to collect preserve and
document the period
she then turns her attention to
methodology and purpose and i can't help
but smile when i read her words as they
echo the fortune off archives training
manual compiled by joanne rudolph and
dana klein
perhaps two of our our most wierbachian
like figures of the fortunate video
archive and i'll quote again from
warrior box manual we must allow the
witness to speak freely and we must
follow the thread as naturally as
possible otherwise we risk losing some
of the trust we built
we must not forget that this testimony
is in fact an autobiography and it's
first and foremost the witness's story
and so with that uh
that's an end quote um
and now i it's my pleasure to introduce
our keynote speaker sam casao
sam is the charles northam professor of
history at trinity college he's the
author of several works uh monographs
and uh innumerable articles his most
recent book was the edited volume called
listen and believe the ghetto reportage
of parrots opachinsky and joseph
zolkovic from yale university university
press in 2015 and his critically
acclaimed work who will write our
history emmanuel ringlebloom and the
oynik chavez archive from indiana
university press that book has been
translated into eight languages
eight languages it received the 2007
orbis prize and was a finalist for the
2008 national jewish book award
sam has been a visiting scholar at
princeton at jts wesleyan many many
others
and has received a list of scholarships
and fellowships far too numerous to name
beyond his scholarship he has made
numerous significant contributions to
the field in other capacities
in particular one highlight would be his
work developing a section of the modern
exhibit at
poland museum in warsaw
and his uh contribution to roberto
grossman's cinematic translation of his
own book who will write our history
which if you have not seen that film is
fantastic and i believe will be screened
at the evil gala in a few weeks
he has also served appointment and
appointments official appointments for
the association of jewish studies and is
on the board of the center for jewish
history and many many other
contributions
finally sam has always been an
incredible supporter of the fortune off
video archive and this support i think
is both intellectual and
personal
he's a member of our honorary advisory
board a lifetime appointment honoring
his enormous scholarly achievements but
also his deep personal connection
after all he is in new haven or yidd
and he spent much of his childhood among
the survivors in new haven and his
mother gave testimony to the fortunate
archive twice once in 1980 and once in
87.
in fact her testimony will be featured
as an episode in the fortune of archives
new podcast series those who were there
to which sam is also contributing by
composing a series of essays for each
episode that provide historical
background and context
sam the archive is grateful for your
guidance and support the generosity with
which you've advised me since i've
returned to yale to take this position
and your assistance with arranging
today's conference please join me in
welcoming sam
[Applause]
thanks a lot and
it's a it's a great honor
to uh
speak at this conference
uh
in
uh
on the legacy of rachel auerbach
a woman who
while she lived got much less
recognition and praise than she deserved
and of course many thanks to the fortune
off video archive
to to stephen nair and deborah bush to
yale university to professor samuel
moyne for making this conference
possible
today we will hear from many scholars
who representing different disciplines
have all done much to help us
better understand
her rich and multifaceted legacy her
life
was linked to such diverse topics
as women in jewish culture
regionalism and folklore her key role
in
the galician journal tsushtaya and the
lon kentness movement
her life was linked to pre-war warsaw as
a yiddish cultural center
of course the oinic shabbos archive in
the warsaw ghetto
the central jewish historical commission
in post-war poland
her involvement in films such as
zunzrikinda which we saw last night her
very fraught career at yad vashem
the eichmann trial where she did yeoman
work behind the scenes to bring survivor
testimony into the courtroom
what annette villavorca called the era
of the witness
came about in no small measure
thanks to the unstinting efforts of
people like
rachel auerbach their efforts to
highlight the importance of survivor
testimony the akhman trial being a key
example
at a time when scholars like raul
hillberg argued that documents were
better sources than survivor accounts
our bach countered yes documents were
well and good
but they were a source that usually had
more to say about perpetrators than
about victims
and long before the work of
long before the recent synthetic history
of shelf friedlander or the work of jan
thomas gross
auerbach insisted
that the voice of the victims be heard
and weighed
that scholars and jurists take survivor
testimony seriously
focusing not just on content but also on
the nuances of body language phrasing
affect
language itself
and so what
if those giving testimony got some dates
and names wrong
their authority of witness
far outweighed mistakes
in the details
auerbach began listening to the victims
as early as
1941 in a soup kitchen in the warsaw
ghetto as early as 1942
as she wrote down the testimony of avram
schapitzki an escapee from trablinka
she did this for the onik shabbos
archive an encounter that changed her
life
as one of only three survivors of the
onyx shabbos archive
rokhalarbak had the opportunity
not only to retrieve her wartime
writings
but to rewrite and
publish them in such books as bihutsat
valsha
valshavatsavas and by mletsten veg
and there were significant differences
between what she wrote during the war
and how she rewrote those same pages
later
as she handed over her first cache of
ghetto writings to the ionic shabbos
on july 26 1942
in the middle of the chaos and horror of
the deportations to treblinka
she attached a note that exposed her
feelings raw fear
violent anger despair
and now i'm quoting
i'm handing over this unfinished essay
to the archive
the fifth day of the acts yom perhaps
such horrors have already occurred in
jewish history but such shame never
jews as tools of the killers i want to
stay alive i'm ready to kiss the boots
of the worst scoundrel
just to be able to see the moment of
revenge revenge revenge
remember
in that same note she wondered whether
her writings would share the same fate
as the scribblings of a coal miner
trapped in an accident with no survivors
whose body would never be found would
anyone read those notes or anyone care
and besides she could no longer write
coherently and if she survived what good
would she be to anybody
fast forward two years to early 1944
she was now on the aryan side with false
papers
she no longer had any doubts she had to
write
this was a debt she owed to the dead but
at the same time she had to be careful
the mass murder the murder of millions
of jews by the germans is a fact that
speaks for itself
it's very dangerous to add to this
subject
interpretations or analyses
anything that is said can quickly turn
into hopeless hysteria or endless sobs
so one must approach the subject with
the greatest caution in a restrained and
factual manner
this has been my intention
not to express
but to transmit
to note only facts but not to
interpret but she quickly added that she
realized immediately
that this mandate was impossible even
for herself
after the war
in poland and in israel
after she'd recovered her wartime
manuscripts her writing would take on
yet another purpose
to ensure that the jewish people
remember not only to keep faith with the
dead
but also to use the lessons of the
holocaust to strengthen the nation and
tighten the bonds between israel and the
diaspora
auerbach left poland for israel in 1950
and while she had many difficulties in
her new home
she never wavered in her conviction
that after the holocaust israel had
become the vital center of the jewish
people and for those who read yiddish i
highly recommend her book in london soil
a book of repertage from the early 1950s
that revealed the devotion to the new
state
as well as her empathy for the struggles
of the new immigrants the jews from the
middle east and north africa no less
than survivors of the holocaust
although her comparisons of certain
yemeni jews the jewish villagers in
rural galicia might be something of a
stretch
like all good reportage our box postwar
books
conveyed what she saw
and observed
an evocative powerful language that made
her writings an indispensable source for
the cultural and social history of the
warsaw ghetto
for auerbach
memory and mourning demanded a painful
return
to the intense vibrant world of pre-war
jewish warsaw
which one of her mentors
the yiddish poet malach
had called a sprawling mosaic of
different jewish worlds
different tribes and subcultures
hasidium polish speaking professionals
litvax
auerbach took the shattered bits and
shards of that world and reconstructed a
mosaic of memory
based on a poignant evocation of dozens
of individual vignettes and thus she
spoke for those who have no one to
remember them the ordinary jews she came
to know in the ghetto as she ran the
soup kitchen on leishno 40 and the
jewish writers artists and actors
whose milieu she shared in the 1930s and
in the war
the more one knew about what
and whom the germans had murdered
the more one could grasp the enormity of
the national hurom the national
catastrophe
as auerbach struggled to describe the
destruction of warsaw jewry
her story lighted into a pledge y.a for
warsaw's particular place
in the history
of the polish jews
in 1945
auerbach recalled
that she had first come to warsaw
exactly 20 years before
during the intermediate days of passover
1925.
just as tens of thousands of jews were
streaming to the gentia cemetery
to dedicate the parrots mausoleum the
ohio parrots which miraculously survived
the war
and now i'm reading anita norwich's
translation
but that was the first time i'd seen
such a thing and i was astonished and
deeply moved
organized and spontaneous delegations
swept through the masses of jews of all
walks of life wearing caps and hats and
yarmulkes businessmen and workers
young and old a mobile forest of people
to my eyes that looked like something
out of asia i could never have seen such
a thing among jews and ulvov
this was jewish warsaw and this was how
it expressed its feelings for one of its
spiritual leaders
as many jews as were then gathered in
the gentia cemetery
are not now to be found in all of poland
around that same time after the war
the writer leo finkelstein a friend of
our box wrote in the samoligay chavasha
that warsaw's strength re re
derived not from husavis
but from not from
its historical tradition but from a
sheer mass in power
warsaw had no encrusted traditions and
thus could serve as a path breaker in
the modernization of jewish
life what finkelstein thought of warsaw
when finkelstein thought of warso what
he emphasized like auerbach where the
crowds the masses of jews who came to
paris funeral to the mayday
demonstrations to see the hasidic
rebbies
by the same token in a post-war essay
comparing vilna and warsaw
the literary critic [ __ ] bellas wrote
is it not symbolic warsaw struggled he
refers to the ghetto uprising vilna
furnished the song the partisan song
although at a critical moment the villa
jews rejected armed rebellion
is this not a reflection of the entire
history of these two great jewish
centers
warsaw earned its place in east european
jewish history because of its quantity
as well as its quality
because of its enormous jewish
population she took first place in the
jewish world
abraham lewin a key member of the oinic
shabbos wrote in late 1942
that warsaw was the nerve center of
polish jewelry
and polish jewelry was the cultural
center of the jewish people
so how could the jewish people survive
this massacre
that lewin who would soon be murdered
probably in treblinka could ask this
question
only underscores the special agony
felt by holocaust victims who before
they died
had to witness the destruction of their
families the destruction of their people
of their language
without any trace of consolation such as
the knowledge for instance
that a jewish state would arise after
the war
if auerbach could do nothing else
she could at least ensure
that posterity remembered what this
great jewish metropolis had meant
before the war auerbach herself admitted
to a certain ambivalence about jewish
war so on the one hand she fiercely
defended the jewish masses
against articles such as a demeaning
reportage charlie long
the dark continent which appeared in an
elite literary journal vyadamoshi
literatsuki
which compared the jews of warsaw to the
denisons of
africa
and saw them as interesting specimens
worth an anthropological study but
little more
auerbach went ballistic and she accused
the author vonda meltzer and by
extension the entire vietnamese
milieu with its heavy representation of
brilliant intellectuals of jewish origin
of pretentious arrogance and ignorance
yet on the other hand
auerbach freely admitted
that before the war she herself had
shared some of the widespread pessimism
about the future of warsaw as a jewish
and more specifically a yiddish cultural
center
she expressed real doubts about the
cultural future of yiddish especially in
light of rampant acculturation and the
economic woes of polish jewry
but after the war she revised her
previous skepticism
it would be easy to dismiss aurobock's
change of heart
as a post-holocaust need to sanctify
what had been destroyed but that would
not be accurate
like her mentor ringlebloom
writing in late 1943 and 44.
auerbach devoted a large part of her
wartime in post-war writings to the
warsaw jewish intelligencia
writers like
calm and lease and joseph kiermann
israel stern
actresses like miriam arleska painters
and sculptors like avrahamus jega and
roman kromstik
composers and choir directors such as
david eisenstadt
she described shia breida her boss in
the elaine hill who had translated
plato's dialogues into yiddish and who
had he only survived would have enriched
the yiddish language beyond compare
if only this play had survived
if only that cantata if only that poem
what she heard in the ghetto she wrote
represented a flowering of jewish genius
a bright flame just before the final
destruction
in her post-war writings auerbach openly
explained
that she had doubted the prospects for
yiddish culture in poland
because she had underestimated the
vitality of the polish jewish masses
it was her work in the elaine hill from
the self-help in the soup kitchens
when she came into close contact not
just with ordinary jews but with the
impressive leaders of the religious
world
that she never would have come to know
had it not been for the war it was then
she began to understand according to her
writings that jewish life was so deeply
rooted the jews were so numerous
that the nation could have counted on
the capital the cultural capital of
polish jewry for generations to come
now i quote
despite everything
we were surrounded with enormously
powerful and dynamic jewish folk masses
too numerous and too rooted in their
culture for acculturation to threaten
the basic character of the nation
the religious strata were an enormous
reservoir of human resources and
spiritual energy
and they would have made up any losses
that we were suffering
towards polish culture
we thought that we had arrived in jewish
warsaw too late
we thought we'd arrived after the best
was already over
in fact the blooms faded only to prepare
for the next harvest of fruit
and this would have happened had it not
been for the terrible catastrophe that
befell us
as soon as the war ended
auerbach resolved to carry on
ringlebloom's legacy
and to find the tin boxes and milkhands
buried under the trackless rubble of
what had been the warsaw ghetto
the yiddish writer mendelman recalled
our box talk the third anniversary
commemoration of the ghetto uprising
after many tiresome speeches full of
political posturing auerbach the only
woman on the podium got up to speak
she didn't make any speeches she didn't
explain the meaning of the uprising with
the stubbornness that deeply affected me
she demanded she called remember she
cried out there is a national treasure
under the ruins even if there are five
stories of ruins we have to find the
archive i'm not making this up i know
what i'm talking about this isn't just
talk this is coming from my heart
i will not rest and i will not let you
rest we must rescue the ring of bloom
archive now many people were skeptical
they had their own troubles they didn't
need the archive to tell them what
they'd been through but auerbach
disagreed
now more than ever survivors have to
organize a systematic and collective
effort to record the past and to
continue the work of the onyx shabbos
the traditions of the ringle bloom
archive could counteract disturbing
trends that she had already noticed in
early post-war memoirs for example
the eminent the memoirs of the eminent
biologist ludwig kirschville a convert
to catholicism where the pianist
vladisov spielman
according to her
presented a skewed
and distorted picture of the ghetto
but one could one expect she asked from
individuals who had been so distant from
jewish society before the war
on the other hand auerbach also attacked
the memoirs and writings
of many nationally conscious jewish
survivors for their tendency to settle
political scores and nurture ideological
jealousies
and this was always a pet peeve of our
box and again she held up the model of
the ionic shabbos where she believed a
shared sense of national mission had
trump political differences in the
aftermath of the catastrophe a wounded
nation had a look at its record the good
as well as the bad to tell the whole
truth to adam subtract nothing this was
a debt owed not just to the victims who
had died
but to the nation that had to recover
and rebuild
auerbach hallowed the exploits of the
ghetto fighters and the partisans but
she did not want their story to
overshadow and diminish
the memory of the 99 percent who had no
weapons
like much of the oink shabbos staff
auerbach was close to the circles of the
pre-war evo the yiddish scientific
institute with its traditions of
breaking down barriers between scholars
and ordinary jews
of zomling a mass movement to collect
documents and source materials
a key goal of the evo was to explore the
every day
sudha tending them height to understand
day daily life
to explore this through surveys
interviews
to encourage personal documents such as
autobiographies
and i highly recommend our box review of
shia parilla's hidden from the gonzo
ordinary jews which appeared in literary
shebleta before the war which really
shows our box closeness to the ethos of
the evil
indeed the very structure of auerbach's
wartime writings
emphasized the close links of the jewish
intelligence in the masses
the first title of her essays on the
murdered writers musicians and artists
was suzaman meet and folk together with
the people
auerbach's work followed in the
footsteps not only of emmanuel
ringlebloom
but also of evo director max weinreich
who made special efforts to incorporate
the insights of sigmund freud and of
social psychology into the study of
polish jewry
in the highly politicized and divided
world of interwar jewish poland
where so many stress the primacy of the
collective over the individual
vine right
in his
youth studies young abortion project for
instance
argued
that one could not understand claudius
trial the collective
without
grasping the needs of rebbi israel the
individual
the aspirations drives obsessions hopes
of the many individuals who made up
polish jewelry
auerbach whose main field of university
study
had been psychology and who had written
extensively on the field in the pre-war
jewish press needed little convincing
and so too in her holocaust
writings
she highlighted she highlighted
the complex interplay of psychological
factors
in individuals families entire social
groups
she told a complicated story
resilience vitality self-sacrifice on
the one hand
corruption and moral collapse on the
other
she also had brilliant insights
the result of conversations with
folklore shmuel laymen in the ghetto
about how rumors jokes street songs
could be seen as a self-defense reflex a
poignant but powerful sign of the
instinctive resistance of the jewish
masses
our box stressed the german skillful use
of psychological
weaponry
to affect the
destruction of warsaw jewry
and to use the jews strengths
against them
the germans played with the jews and
with their natural human
instincts of self-preservation and hope
in her brilliant observations of the
mass hysteria that gripped the warsaw
ghetto in the summer of 1942
to get into a shop to bribe people to
get a worse certificate auerbach
described how the very qualities that
had served jews so well in the past
practicality pragmatism hard-headedness
cycle
and natural optimism
now accelerated their journey into the
abyss
and now i quote and still
other jews
broad shoulder deep voice with powerful
hands and hearts artisans workers wagon
drivers porters jews who with the blow
of their fist could floor eddie hooligan
who dared entered their neighborhoods
where were you this is leonard wolf's
translation by the way where were you
when your wives and children when your
fathers and mothers were taken away
what happened to make you run off like
cattle stampeded by fire
was there no one to give you some
purpose in the confusion you were swept
away by the flood together with those
who were weak
and you sly cunning merchants
philanthropists in your short fur coats
and hats
how was it that you didn't catch on to
the murderous swindle
now with other peoples confronted with
this similar massive assault have acted
better she did not think so
did warsaw jewry eventually recover from
the shock and fight back yes
should one blame the jewish masses for
not having fought back earlier
only those who had not been there our
bakken plot would do so
was armed resistance the only way
that jews stood up to the germans
absolutely not
auerbach was a superb observer of the
jewish every day as i said she had a
fine sense
of the nuances of the behavior and
speech of different classes of polish
jews whether they lived in small towns
or in urban centers like warsaw
like ringlebloom she was a native of
southeast galicia
before moving with her family to evolve
she'd spent her childhood in a remote
village not a stettle in padolia
lanavids
where she acquired a love of jewish
folklore in the yiddish language
the great jewish folklorist and
ethnographer shmuel layman had
interviewed her many times about the
folk songs and customs of the rural
pedolian jews
like many other galician jews auerbach
combined this steep jewish identity
with the first class polish education
cultural sensibility
at alvov university in the early 1920s
auerbach befriended the young poetist
vora fogle and the budding writer and
painter bruno schultz and she urged both
to start writing in yiddish and fogel
indeed did so
in 1929 she helped begin sue steyer a
literary journal that tried to bring the
polish-speaking galician jewish
intelligentsia closer to yiddish
auerbach would go on to have many
interests but one of the most salient
was her devotion from a very young age
to get her secular culture her vision of
that culture was inclusive rather than
exclusive one that united rather than
divide it that transcended political
differences
a culture whose creativity would shame
those who regarded yiddish as nothing
more than a low-class jargon
but in the end
sushdair was a bridge too far
it folded in 1932 after three issues
unable to overcome financial
difficulties and disagreements over
politics
for our bachelor's culture came first
politics second but others disagreed
and one more thing
as she started the journal
she had to endure some condescending and
misogynistic sniping aimed at her and a
dvoraphogo
this might have been the first such
incident in her life but it was
definitely not the last in the late
nineteen thirties in warsaw she earned
the nickname de literary shabailage
the literary supplement
a snide reference to her relationship
with itsec monger
and later on she would wonder if her
path in yad vashem would have been
easier
had she not been a woman
but that only encouraged auerbach to
redouble her efforts to highlight the
critical contributions of women to
yiddish literature
despite her love of galicia and
of ulvov she realized that yidashi
culture faced the bleak future there in
the 1930s she moved in 1932 she moved to
warsaw
after her brief marriage to the poet
bear schnapper failed she became the
companion of the brilliant and
tempestuous yiddish poet itsecmonger and
supported herself pricary precariously
by translation and by writing articles
and reviews for the jewish press in
polish and yiddish
much of the power of our bach's
reportage stem from her ability to
navigate cultural boundaries
derived from a life that straddled many
different worlds village stetel and city
yiddish and polish poles and jews
galician warsaw the milieu of the jewish
literary elite and the world of the
jewish masses
religious and secular diaspora
nationalists and zionists she straddled
them all
at the end of september 1939
after poland's capitulation
auerbach was about to flee to wolves
when she received an unexpected summons
from emmanuel ringabloom to stay in
warsaw and run a soup kitchen again i'm
basing this on what she wrote
most of the jewish elite had run away
from warsaw but ringlebloom had reminded
auerbach that not everyone had the right
to run
ringlebloom thus brought auerbach into
the far-flung network of the self-help
the elaine hill
of the warsaw ghetto with its hundreds
of house committees dozens of soup
kitchens day care centers
and
refugee shelters
the leaders of the elaine hill saw the
organization as the conscience of warsaw
jewry a counterweight to the udon rod
during world war one the yiddish writer
yitzhak labush paris had stressed the
interdependence of relief and zomling
the recording of history and in the
second world war by the same token the
elaine hills made the functioning of the
onyx shabbos archive possible
ringlebloom used the soup kitchens and
refugee centers to gather information to
camouflage the gathering of information
and to find writers and at the same time
by giving them jobs he tried to save the
cash raise of the jewish intelligentsia
in 1941
he recruited auerbach to the onyx
shabbos by asking her to write about the
soup kitchen and aurebak would stress
that had it not been for ringle bloom
she would not have written anything
our box soup kitchen on leishno 40
which fed 2 000 jews a day
offered her a unique vantage point to
get to know and observe a large number
of quote-unquote customers
the story that auerbach told provided a
gripping behind-the-scenes look
at the desperate battle that the ghetto
was waging against hunger
auerbach and investigated the social
history of hunger
by telling the story of a soup kitchen
as a microcosm of human relationships
and human choices
the dead who ended up in the pits of the
gentia cemetery were not an
undifferentiated mass but individuals
whose idiosyncrasies auerbach recorded
she deftly caught the phrases or the
habits that made these individuals
memorable the young mother expelled from
her stettle
who arrived at the soup kitchen with
four children in tow
and a tot suckling at her breast
a family of solid rugged jewish boys
from a country farm who had just been
expelled
and each day they take a bowl of soup
for their aged father and whenever they
mentioned him they never failed to add
in
swansea may he live to 120.
many solid members of the jewish middle
class now reduced to desperate poverty
auerbach
as the director of the soup kitchen
confronted serious psychological
pressures and moral challenges
like other figures of the elaine hill
she had seen herself as an honest public
servant imbued with the moral code of
the progressive jewish intelligencia but
very quickly she discovered that for the
masses of starving desperate people who
came to the kitchen each day she
represented authority and power in their
eyes she had become an arbiter of life
and death like ringlebloom she had come
from a milieu that was imbued with love
for quote-unquote the jewish masses
but now these masses those ordinary jews
stormed her office blocked her in the
corridors and begged for extra soup
tickets
they looked at our back as someone who
could save them some confronted her in
silence supplication others yelled and
loudly reminded her of their former
status then there were the children who
would come in packs and cajole her in
yiddish accented polish plush upon the
pleasurepani for some extra food
and it seemed to her
then
as if the kitchen only prolonged the
agony but really saved no one
should she favor a chosen few or dole
out equal rations and save no one
ringlebloom asked the same question
increasingly frustrated
our box singled out a chosen few for
special care
the religious poet israel stern for
instance
or a german-speaking refugee from the
sudetenland who had survived daca
and whom bringlebloom wanted to keep
alive as a witness
this former athlete the dutch as he was
called in warsaw yiddish one hour back
over with his impeccable manners his
good nature his spry sense of humor for
our bach brockmire became a litmus test
in a challenge she bent her rules and
gave him extra food when he began to
become apathetic a common sign of
starvation she would yell at him that
she could feed him but that he had to
summon up the will to live it was
important auerbach felt to win at least
one victory
but here too she failed
in her diary entry of august 4th 1941
she noted that
what is the use of all our work if we
can't save even one person from death by
hunger
ringeloom soon gave her new assignments
in september 1942
he and shmuel vinter asked auerbach to
interview avraham chapitsky who just
escaped from treblinka
and there was a protocol of more than a
hundred pages written by auerbach
schapitzki did not survive but after the
war auerbach developed a special bond
with the treblinka survivors
about whom she wrote in the late 1940s
and whose honor she defended in the
1960s during the controversy over
steiner's book in february 1943 she
escaped to the aryan side
and held by polish friends she procured
alien documents and became a courier for
the jewish underground
on the aryan side after the ghetto
uprising auerbach wrote a constant
stream of essays for what she called
archive hemshach the continuation
archive with the help of polish friends
auerbach buried her writings in two
different locations in warsaw on the
grounds of the zoo and in a field in the
southern district of makoto both cassius
survived the war as auerbach wrote i had
better luck in saving paper
than in saving people
one of the greatest of her wartime works
one of the very few translated into
english was yiskar
first written she said
in late 1943
and we'll hear more about this from
david roski's sitting on a warsaw
trolley car she'd seen a polish woman
weeping over her son who the germans had
shot
and auerbach realized
that she didn't have the luxury of
openly mourning
and so she went back to her apartment so
she wrote and began her great allergy
for warsaw jewelry yusker
i may neither grow nor weep i may not
draw attention to myself in the street
and i need to groan i need to weep not
four times a year i feel the need to say
iskar four times a day yiskur is the
service of remembrance the prayer of
remembrance
she poured out her soul
as she tried to describe the murder of
warsaw jewry the toddlers the children
who she remembered from the ghetto
schools the tough jewish workers the
hardened women shopkeepers young scouts
courting couples
intellectuals all gone
even if a few individuals survived
the vibrant raucous and diverse mosaic
of warsaw jewry had been destroyed
yisker humanized the victims
by recalling not only their
individuality but also their city the
specific urban milieu that had shaped
them and that had made them valshavo
in other essays she wrote auerbach
indeed regretted the lack of armed
resistance until january 1943
but yisker was different
unlike the works of some other ionic
shabbos writers who observed the
deportation like shia parilla israel
liechtenstein or paris of pochinski
was suffused with empathy
towards jews rather than anger as david
roski's has pointed out by using the
imagery of a flood of a natural disaster
at the beginning of yuskar she
anticipated future questions that those
who were not there would pose
no the mass murder was not a medica
meta-historical event
but its enormity was too horrible and
too
to allow for glib theories and facile
questions that might compromise the
memory of the ordinary jews she
cherished so deeply
and how does one resist a flood
or an earthquake what befell the jewish
masses was so unthinkable and so
calamitous that they were
psychologically unprepared
implicitly auerbach was anticipating the
invidious distinctions that many would
make after the war between the few who
fought back with weapons and the masses
that allegedly died without a fight it
was the people she wrote about nyscore
not the fighters who'd written up who's
risen up just months before
and in the end the secular writer could
only repeat the words of the traditional
yusuke prayer for auerbach
yisker was a return not to religion but
to the murdered world of her birth to a
folk community that did not have to
invent new words to describe pain and
loss they were already there in the
prayers like her murdered friends
auerbach was suzanne meet and folk
together with the people
one of the more striking features of our
box writings of this period is her
portrayal of poland in the polls
as a courier who distributed money and
aid to hidden jews
auerbach was in constant contact with a
category very small in number
of polls
who most jews during the war never had a
chance to meet the liberal intellectual
elite
her descriptions of such individuals as
jan jabinsky and his wife are
particularly instructive and insightful
jabinski had been the director of the
warsaw zoo
as well as an officer in the polish
underground during the war he and his
wife had helped many jews including
auerbach herself
her intense devotion to the memory of
jewish warsaw in no way
diminished her deep empathy for polish
warsaw in its sufferings
in valshavats voice
she painted a sympathetic portrait of
warsaw's mayor stefan staginski who
called out his fellow citizens to resist
the germans
and who led the city during the days of
the terrible siege in september 1939
right after a terrible bombardment of
jewish neighborhoods
staging paid a visit
and stroked the heads of jewish children
perhaps auerbach speculated as he walked
through those jewish streets strazzinski
was thinking how before the war
poland had treated its jews as
second-class citizens at least that's
what she wrote
perhaps the terror of the siege had one
silver lining for a brief moment the
fight against the common german enemy
brought poles and jews together and
offered another glimpse into the heart
of what might have been
before the war starzinski had to put it
mildly he'd not been known as a phyllo
semi
but like so many others auerbach
speculated perhaps the war caused him to
grow beyond himself
many people
auerbach noted
would wonder
why starzinski and his fellow poles
defended warsaw in september 1939.
it was such a hopeless fight that led to
so many needless civilian casualties
another warsaw jewish diarist heim
kaplan had nothing but contempt for a
doomed battle that caused so much
suffering but auerbach nurtured on
polish romanticism was full of
admiration and i quote
romanticism
idealism
let the naysayers get the contempt they
deserve
other europeans peoples did not fight
but we polish jews understand what the
polls did
we were at their side and we understand
today
now our bach's relationship to poland
was paradoxical and complicated and
hopefully we will hear more about the
subject later on especially from
carolina
auerbach the idiotist actually did most
of her wartime writing in polish
and in her book of reportage in londus
royal
she spoke about jews leaving poland
after the war for israel carrying
yastran's biography of adam mitzkevich
and in that same book she wrote about
the final days before she left poland
forever
to go to israel and she remembered that
when her grandparents had left galicia
before world war one
they had spent months
going from shtetl to stettel
saying goodbye to multiple relatives
now she was leaving poland and she
didn't have one relative to say goodbye
to she'd lost everyone
but whom did she visit
she spent those final days with the
polish family who had been her childhood
neighbors when she'd lived in lanovitz
as a young girl and who after the war
had uh moved to the former german
territories in the west her description
of that visit
that kind of
end of us of a chapter in her life
underscored the close bonds that she
felt had existed between poles and jews
in that distant rural past
and of course auerbach was no fool
during the time she was in poland about
1500 jews were murdered by
bipolars
and
i'm not saying her attitude towards
poland was one of unalloyed ad
admiration but there was certainly an
element of paradox here
in the tension between her wartime
writings
and
her post-war remundations one can
discern a marked shift
not just in subject matter but an
emphasis in attitude
in her wartime writings and reportage
for the archive
auerbach judged herself harshly the soup
kitchen had been a failure the elaine
hilf an exercise in futility but after
the war she realized the kitchens had
been more effective than she thought
and that polish yiddish culture as i
said had a future
the same pattern of self-criticism
followed by positive re-evaluation
emerged in other post-war writings
after the war she joined the central
jewish historical commission in poland
where philip friedman joseph kerbish
michael borovich and others were busily
documenting the holocaust and publishing
the first serious studies
at the time she focused on the defects
rather the achievements of the of the
historical commission
but
and she
thought that
they were falling short
but in israel in the 1950s she changed
her tomb
compared to the paltry record of
scholarship on the holocaust in israel
and elsewhere in the 1950s she now wrote
that post-war poland had been a golden
age of holocaust research
in israel at yad versame her
single-minded determination to
foreground holocaust research and the
collection of survivor testimony caused
major conflicts which boss cohn will
talk about it is sad but true that her
last years in israel were not happy ones
our bach to put it mildly was not an
easy person to get along with and i
sense that in her last years she felt a
great deal of bitterness and frustration
and so to return to what i said earlier
in conclusion
we are not only here to talk about an
important woman
but we're also here to right or wrong
and i would like to end this talk by
quoting something of parrot says that
auerbach repeated in 1945
when surveying the rubble of warsaw she
thought back to the legacy
of this great tribune of modern
yiddishkeit who had once sought to
inspire a new jewish culture in poland
in eastern europe anchored in both
jewish tradition and european humanism
and i used anita norwich's translation
from her book discovering exile console
my people it needs consolation
strengthen its heart shore up its spirit
don't be the wind that puts out the
flame
instead pour oil intend the wick because
night is poison and despair
death console my people it needs
consolation
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you